صناعه التكنولوجيا في الولايات المتحده
مضطربه مع اعلان الشركات الامريكيه عن
تخفيضات في الوظائف اكثر مما كان متوقعا
في السابق امازون هي احدث شركه تقرر تخفيض
الوظائف وسبقتها الاسبوع الماضي شركه ميتا
الشركه الام لفيسبوك معلنه انها ستلغي ما
يقرب من عشره الاف وظيفه خلال الاشهر
المقبله في الموجه الثانيه من عمليات
التسريح الجماعي للعمال
وللاطلاع على سبب هذه التسريحات سالنا
الموظف الذي خسر عمله في متى في الدوره
الاولى من التخفيضات لنستمع
اعتقد انها قرارات تجاريه فاشله لا احد
لديه طابه بلوريه يمكن اعتبار ان الشركه
تملكها القليل من الجشع مع الكثير من عدم
اليقين واتخذت بعض القرارات التي لم تكن
رائعه انا لا الوم احد لكن الى جانب ذلك
اتى الوباء الذي جعل الاشياء تبدو مذهله
للقطاع الالكتروني بسبب الطلب المتزايد
حينها
التخوف الان من ان يشكل عدد الموظفين
المسرحين ضغطا كبيرا على القطاع الذي
يكافح الان للبقاء وعلى الاقتصاد الامريكي
بشكل عام هذا ما يقوله مايك كبير مستشار
سياسه الالكترونيه في معهد
لن اسمي ما يحدث بالازمه انها مهمه ولكنها
ليست ازمه ما يحدث هو تغيير طبيعي من
الاتجاه الاخر من التوظيف الذي قامت به كل
هذه الشركات في هذا الوباء من ميته الى
امازون الى جوجل هناك الكثير من العوامل
المختلفه وليست بسبب الموظفين